Now that we've talked a little bit
about inheritance and other object-oriented concepts,
I want to now move on about controllers and pawn classes,
as these do slightly different things
but can be somewhat confusing at first.
So the first thing that we're gonna talk about
is a controller class.
Now, the controller class is a digital representation
of whatever physical input device
is currently being used.
So whether the player is using a mouse and a keyboard,
a controller, a plastic guitar, an Arduino board,
whatever they are using to send out input,
that is gonna be taken by our controller classes.
Now, there are two controller classes that you will see.
There is the player controller and the AI controller.
Now, the AI controller is simply
when you are trying to mimic input
that a player would use,
and it is kind of outside the scope of our talk.
So that's about all we're gonna talk about,
the AI controller.
The player controller, on the other hand,
is something that we are going to use,
and controllers do something called possession.
And what they possess is something called the pawn.
And when something is possessed,
its inputs pass through the player controller
down into the pawn,
controlling it and displaying movement.
So we can think of the player
kind of like a spirit that controls an avatar.
The reason that we wanna do this is,
let's say that we have a game
that supports multiple inputs.
We have mouse and keyboard, we have a controller,
and this game also has multiple vehicle types.
There is a human, there's a horse, there's a car,
there's a helicopter.
However, what we want to have happen
is that whenever a player is playing
on the mouse and keyboard,
whenever they go to press forward,
no matter if they're a horse or a car
or a tractor or a rocket ship,
we always want W to make them go forward,
A to make them go left, D to make them go right,
and S to go backwards.
And by establishing our movements
and things inside of our player controller,
what we do is we allow our players
to use the same movement components
and the same movement inputs,
no matter what type of pawn
they're having to be possessing.
Now, you might be wondering,
well, you keep talking about this thing called pawn.
What is a pawn?
Well, a pawn is just simply a class
that takes the input passed from the user or the AI
and takes that movement and processes it
into the actual movement and interaction
that you're seeing on the screen.
Now, when you're dealing with pawn,
you're gonna see two kind of subclasses.
There's a pawn and there is a character class.
The difference between the two is that pawn is a simple,
basically kind of like a ghost
that will float in the world and collide with objects.
The character class though,
that gives us a more advanced movement.
It gives us a capsule component
and a skeletal mesh component
that represents the visual representation of that.
Generally speaking, all character monsters
and vehicles will derive from either pawn
or the character class, depending on what it's used for.
And again, it's best to keep things split up
in this manner where we have our controller
controlling our various pawns,
as this will ensure that we don't have to have code
in multiple locations
and that the end user isn't surprised
whenever a new mechanic is introduced
or they utilize a new type of vehicle.